the warnings had been ominous an attack
by the russian military would begin in
eastern ukraine before the sun would
rise a threat that russian president
vladimir putin followed through with
after weeks of developing a military
posture along ukraine's border
consisting of roughly two 200 000 troops
there was a global push late wednesday
to bring the kremlin back from the brink
the united nations security council
convening an emergency meeting tonight
russia has brought its people the
ukrainian people and the world
to the brink of a conflict that will
produce an untold amount of human
suffering bob ray canada's ambassador to
the u.n adding vladimir putin's war
crimes cannot go unanswered only minutes
after russian troops were told to lay
down their arms social media became a
window into the new reality showing the
impacts of what appeared to be missiles
being launched into ukraine the white
house quick to respond saying the world
will hold russia accountable noting it
will be responsible for the death and
destruction this attack will bring the
attack comes only days after an address
from vladimir putin decrying ukraine's
sovereignty arguing its government was
carrying out a genocide against ethnic
russians an unsubstantiated claim seen
as pretext for this assault
in a last attempt to stave off an
operation that threatened his country's
future ukraine's leader spoke to russian
citizens in their native tongue on the
devastation war will have on both
ukrainians and russians alike russia's
u.n envoy is not calling this a war
rather a special military operation one
the world attempted to stop using
sanctions that didn't act as a deterrent
and has left rules-based order under the
ultimate threat
reggie chikini global news washington